the single greatest lesson i ever
learned in my career that profoundly
changed the course of my life was
multiple time best selling author third
most watched ted talk of all time the
return of simon sinek thank you very
much plus 30 40 years we've doubled down
at how do i find love how do i find
happiness we've doubled down on
selfishness but now in a complicated
messy world we haven't been practicing
and developing the skills of taking care
of each other and that's what we need
now more than ever do you ever give up
on someone um
[Music]
i have a fear i've never expressed this
openly gen z are the least resilient
generation they're really good at
presenting a confidence
that they don't have this young
generation seems less capable to deal
with stress than previous generations
that is true going from relationship to
relationship to relationship from job to
job to job there's no stigma to quitting
flash forward five years and what's
going to happen is an employer is going
to look at them be like
i can't take the risk everything we're
talking about today comes right back to
those human skills that we are lacking
how to listen how to give and receive
feedback how to have a difficult
conversation and the thing we have to
deal with more than anything is fear
fear that is the underlying thing why we
don't have honest conversations
let me give you some honesty then
what is the greatest fear you have about
how you're currently living your life i
was very insecure about admitting that
i was crying
you know as we were talking about it
that was that was hard
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
simon good to see you again yeah good to
be here um i i have to thank you first
and foremost and i many reasons you know
i'm a huge fan of all your work but the
conversation we had when we're over in
l.a was received so unbelievably well by
the listeners on this podcast it did
millions and millions and millions of
downloads in such a short space of time
that i had to argue to get you to come
back again when you're here in the uk so
well it's nice to be back and it's nice
to do it on your home turf yeah
literally in my home literally in your
home um
there's so many things i want to talk to
you about but one of the things that i
was curious about because i've been
thinking a lot about this in my life is
this idea of our whys evolving
what is your why and has it evolved over
the last decade at all
uh so my why
[Music]
is to inspire people to do the things
that inspire them
so together each of us can change our
world for the better and it's why i wake
up every morning every day it is the
greatest compliment someone can pay me
when they say to me that was inspiring
or you were inspiring like that feeds me
you know um and the interesting thing
about hawaii is because it is not it is
objective
a y is the sum total of how we were
raised
it's born out of the patterns and the
lessons we learned from our parents from
our teachers when we're young and our
why is fully formed by the time we're in
our mid to late teens and you only have
one wife for the rest of your life it
doesn't change
you ha you are who you are based on how
you were raised now you may not be
acting
as your true self you know people say
that to us all the time you know it's
like i don't know who you are anymore
you know but when you are at your
natural best you're wise front and
center but we're not always acting at
our natural best and sometimes we make
decisions out of selfishness we shake we
take the job that pays us that offers us
the most money and turn down the one to
work for somebody who would probably be
a better mentor you know we do these
things all the time and so
you know can you tweak the words of your
why of course you know but that's that's
semantics um can we find better ways to
to bring a why to life yes that's the
evolution but the why itself is fixed
when you talk about the why being
influenced by the things that happened
in our life our experiences our
upbringing
does that mean that our trauma can
influence our wife for better or for
worse always for better always for
better yeah a why is always positive
um
uh and i'll give you a real life example
of somebody's why discovery that i did
and you know one of the things i do when
i do somebody's my discovery i asked
them about you know happy experiences
when they were kids and this person said
i didn't have a very happy childhood i
had a really bad childhood
and i said okay so tell me tell me a bad
memory then you know
and
she talked about a lot of abuse in the
household and a very abusive alcoholic
father who would beat
her mother and the kids
and she told a story of a repeated
pattern of when the father would be
drunk and come looking for the kids that
she'd be hiding
in the cupboard
protecting her brother with her arms
wrapped around him so to shield her
brother
and she goes through this whole story
and at the end
i pointed out to her that she's a
protector
that in the in these traumatic
experiences it was her instinct
to to protect her baby brother and she's
lived her life if you look at all of the
times that she's really thrived and
where she's her her best self she's
usually in a in a position of protection
of other of other people and that's
where she finds joy in taking care of
other people and so the the experiences
mold us into who we are um and the
effects
you know the impact will be positive
regardless of where it comes from so
yeah i mean
a horrible childhood that made her a
wonderful human being
i was going to use me as an example
there to try and rebuttal that somewhat
but i remember having a very similar
conversation with a very good friend of
mine a week ago
upstairs who talked to me about their
childhood there they've talked about
this publicly as well so i'm not letting
the cat out of the bag but their their
father used to beat their mother up
really really severely and she was
telling me literally just a few days ago
upstairs
that she her memories of trying to hold
on to her dad's arm as it swung for her
mother when she was five years old and
when you look at the pattern of what
those early experiences have caused
and a few other experiences she's
obsessed with
with with helping others
and she's you know building these
amazing businesses she's unbelievably
successful it's like frighteningly
successful at a very very young age
however
that
forcing her to help others
has meant that she's compromised
sometimes helping herself
and
of everyone i know in my life
she is the most successful woman i know
but she's also the woman that is most
unsuccessful in all of the personal
aspects relationships boyfriend
uh mental health all of these things
so when we say you know i understand the
positive side of it but
the negative side of it seems to be
um of this unbelievable i guess why
she's got seems to just honestly for me
not be worth it
[Music]
because this is not this is not someone
that is that would say they're happy
this is someone that is in therapy and
is every day
in tears and upset while serving the
world in an unbelievable way
so is that a positive is that a positive
why so
so
the
the rub about the why you know a y is
basically the thing we give to the world
it's the value we have in other people's
lives her friends would say of her that
she is our protector
um you know uh
that is the role we fill in their lives
which is why they love us because we're
br we're giving them our why it is our
value the rub
the most difficult thing about the why
to understand is the the thing that we
give to to the world is also the thing
that we need the most
it's it's always balanced
and so i would argue that
you know
she
it's not that she's unable to take care
of herself
it's that she needs to find friends
colleagues whatever it is who are
committed to taking care of her
and that's where the change happens
and
you know
we were talking about this you know
before the show started you know there's
an entire section of the bookshop called
self-help and there's no section in the
bookshop called help others
and i believe what we need is the help
of this industry
um i'll tell you uh something uh
something that happened to me a friend
of mine was going through a really
rough patch in her life um her marriage
was
struggling her career was struggling she
was unhappy like just
none of the boxes were getting checked
you know
and she knows what i do i mean we've
been friends for forever and she asked a
favor can you help me
you know of course of course i said and
every week we had a standing
90-minute meeting
where she'd come over and she would tell
me what's going on
and i would give her some advice and i'd
point out some patterns and she'd feel
fantastic she would leave on a high and
she'd feel amazing for like two days and
then it'll go right back again and she'd
come back the following week and this
went on for months two days three days
and then back down again right
and then it occurred to me like i
remember my own work
in leaders eat last i talk about
alcoholics anonymous where they have 12
steps to help an alcoholic beat this
disease
and alcoholics anonymous knows
that if you master 11 of the 12 steps
you're going to probably slide back and
succumb to the disease but if you can
master the 12th step as well
you will more likely beat the disease
the 12th step is to help another
alcoholic
it's service
and so i remembered my own work and i
decided to do a little i decided to
change things up right and so i said to
her look
i love that you come and see me every
week and i love helping you every week
but you know i struggle with things too
and i don't have anybody to talk to
would you be willing to help me maybe we
can split the time and she said of
course yes and what started to happen is
every week we got together and i was
genuine i wasn't faking it like i would
unload and tell her what i was going
through and what i was struggling with
and it ended up that we wouldn't split
the time it ended up that she would
spend 90 minutes talking about my stuff
right and she was the advice giver and
she was the one looking for the patterns
and she would leave on a high and that
high would stay until the following week
it was only when we reversed
the scenario where that she was
had the opportunity to take care of
someone she loved that she was able to
find the solutions to her own challenges
and i'm a great believer that that we
have to remember we're social animals
we need each other and this is the great
paradox of being human at every moment
of every day we are both individuals and
members of groups
you know and there's a there's a there's
a debate do you take care of yourself
first or do you take care of others
first and there's a whole school of
thought that says you have to take care
of yourself first because if you're not
healthy you can't take care of others
and there's a whole school of thought
that says no you have to take care of
others first so that when you're in need
they'll be there for you and the answer
is you're both right and you're both
wrong it's a paradox it's a struggle and
every day we're faced with sometimes big
but often small choices
do i prioritize myself at the sacrifice
of the group or do i prioritize the
group at the sacrifice of myself
and you know folks like um
uh uh
maslov like maslow's hierarchy of needs
maslow made him a huge mistake in that
hierarchy which is
his his baseline our basic need is food
and shelter right
i've never heard of anyone dying by
suicide because they were hungry i've
heard of people dying by suicide because
they were lonely
right and yet social relationships in in
maya's law's hierarchy is number three
but that kind of that doesn't sound
right
it seems like there's something more
important to human beings than just food
and shelter and then the top of the peak
is self-actualization which sounds the
most selfish thing in the world like i
am so self-actualized that i would
literally sit on top of a pyramid and
look down at all of you unactualized
people because that's my goal to be
self-actualized
he's half right the mistake that maslov
made he's the only thought of us as
individuals
and as individuals yes i need food and
shelter first but as a member of a group
i need friends and i need love
and self-actualization is not the thing
i'm actually in pursuit of as a member
of a group it's shared actualization
that i'm looking for
and unfortunately for various reasons
which we don't have to go down that
rabbit hole
the past 30 40 years
especially in the west we have doubled
down on on individualism we have doubled
down on
my own career we've doubled down at how
do i find love how do i find happiness
we've doubled down on selfishness
and it worked for a while it worked when
the economy was really good like in the
80s and 90s and 2000s so awesome
selfishness was great because it worked
but now in a complicated messy world
where the economy isn't great and
everything's not roses
all that self-interest is now
not working except we haven't been
practicing and developing the school
skills of taking care of each other
and that's what we need now more than
ever
and so
i don't know your friend and so i can't
make any i'm not i can't make any
conclusions
but we are we are animals in balance
right and nature
abhors a vacuum
and so whenever i hear about these
things my question is always about the
balance so for example every single good
thing that happens in our lives
everything comes at a cost
there's nothing for free somebody with
an incredible career has no relationship
with their kids right everything comes
at a cost but at the same time
everything we struggle with has
opportunity and lesson that goes with it
it's always balanced
right and so
whenever anybody tells me this great
thing i was like yeah but at what cost
and was the cost worth it sometimes the
answer is yes and sometimes the answer
is no and when something horrible
happens in someone's life or something
goes sideways i always ask but what did
you learn
you know i mean my career and yours is
the same you know
the whole the golden circle and the
concept of why came out of
me losing my passion and hating work
i went through depression i never want
to go through that again but i'm really
glad it happened
because it
look what it's it's given me an entirely
new life view
and i think of strengths and weaknesses
the same way you know i think it's
hilarious when people say what are your
strengths and what are your weaknesses
well it depends
life is balanced and it's always
contextual and everything that we have
that's a strength has liability attached
and every weakness we have has strength
that's attached
i can imagine because of the books
you've written and the you know the
channels you have and the content you
produce that a lot of people come to you
um on a personal level friends family to
help solve some of the problems that
they're having in their lives i i find
myself in somewhat of a similar position
maybe they're not coming to me maybe i'm
inserting myself into the problem to try
and solve it because that's my nature
but do you do you ever do you ever give
up on someone
something i've thought about and i'm i'm
reflecting on my friend a little bit
here yeah and friends i've had from my
childhood who i've i've i remember
offering a guy
i was like if you can just do one month
working in
subway where he was working i'll pay for
your rent so you can move out of that
city yeah and go get a job he didn't do
the one month in subway yeah and at one
point there's part of me he's like you
know everyone's solvable the optimism
the optimistic in me and the other part
of me goes at some point you have to
give up on people
um so the single greatest lesson i ever
learned in my career that profoundly
changed the course of my life and it
comes right before
the the realization and the articulation
of why
i learned
how to ask for help and i learned how to
accept it when i was offered
okay
and i think that it's not about giving
up on someone it's that it's a it's that
it's a
that helping someone is a team sport
success is a team sport and if you find
that you're the only player in in their
life
when they should be the primary player
you can only be you can only do the
assists you'll never be the one making
the baskets that's their job
right
but if they won't take the pass
then at some point you stop throwing the
ball
and um
it's not about giving up on people
it's it's that they have it's about
accountability to take responsibility
for oneself and and giving up on
somebody is don't ever call me again you
don't take my advice this is over
right that's giving up on someone
for i think the other way to do it is
like listen
i i cannot help you if you cannot be
involved to help yourself
and i will want to sit down with them
and i will want to i won't criticize and
be like you're not doing this you have
to follow my advice you have to do this
you got to go work at subway for the
week like that that's not what i want to
sit down and understand what the
blockage is there's something else
that's the blockage that i can get to
hopefully but at the end of the day i
will say to them point blank listen
if you're not going to be involved in
this then there's no point to me to be
involved you know you have to
like this is a team and i'm the only
player here
so i will always be here
and when you are ready maybe it's just
bad timing i don't know what else is
going on in your life and maybe this is
not the right time or maybe i'm a bad
fit
but when you are ready i will still be
here no matter what but you have to call
me
there's no more there's no more me
throwing you the ball like you're gonna
have to call me and then they call you
and then sometimes you do sometimes they
don't sometimes they do sometimes they
don't in my case they call me and and
then they say it's time i'm willing to
accept the help and then the same cycle
happens over and over again and you go
you go you know five years of them
calling you then you then then then it's
then they're lying
but they don't think they're lying they
always think this time is going to be
different i'm going to do it on monday
i mean
like i said i want to know what else is
the blockage you you when there's that
kind of repeated pattern
then there's something else and i think
i think you know our mistake in those
situations is repeating our pattern
which is okay i'm going to give you the
same advice i'm going to do the same
thing you're going to do the same thing
i'm going to tell you the same thing i'm
going to give up on you i'm going to go
like
we're we're actually repeating a pattern
as well and so
you know we know this as entrepreneurs
which is you got to try something
completely completely different
um and i think you know this goes back
to what we were saying a moment ago you
know which is we we are we are not
teaching the skills of how to help
others and part of one of the biggest
skills of learning to help others is
learning how to listen
and most of us are really crap at
listening
right we confuse um listening with
hearing the words that were spoken
you know you're sitting watching tv
and you know someone you love is trying
to tell you something and you're like
uh-huh uh-huh and you're still watching
you're not even listening to me and we
turn around and repeat all the words
back to them that's not listening that's
hearing the words that were spoken to
you
you listening is when the other person
feels heard
right
and where you are in pursuit of meaning
not the word spoken you're not so
literal right
and
i think in the cases of of like your
friend
the the
is to go from an advice giving mode and
men suffer from this more than women
which is we our intention is to fix
everything right all we want to do is
fix fix fix fix we see the problem
here's the solution but sometimes that's
not what people need people need to feel
seen and heard and understood and maybe
just maybe you're going too quickly to
fix and he doesn't feel seen or heard or
understood yet and in this particular
situation
and again i don't know the person but um
i would i would go to an extreme
listening you know give the kid the
opportunity to empty his bucket like and
there's only three terms you're going to
use in the conversation go on tell me
more what else
because there's it sounds like there's
it's whatever you think the thing is
you're fixing it's probably something
entirely different and until you can get
to that um you're going to give up them
somebody who maybe
um it's just that we had the wrong
strategy
it wasn't until these examples surfaced
in my life where i had friends asking me
for this kind of help that i started to
consider that maybe mindset itself is a
privilege one that if you don't
acknowledge and understand you'll end up
giving advice from a very privileged
place you know you know i might say well
just work harder or just yeah just cheer
up yeah these kinds of things come from
like a a misunderstanding that my brain
is fortunate enough to to think and be a
certain way yeah um but i've never heard
someone people talk enough about this
idea that our mindset in and of itself
is a privilege and that you know
that's interesting that mindset is a
privilege
is that true if we think about the early
upbringing in childhood then yeah so
that was maybe you know some people have
monetary privilege from their childhood
one thing that your parents or your
experiences might have given you a real
psychological privilege
so let me just think out loud for a
second right let's try let me try and
unpack that
you know
there are
many stories of people
who
when the odds were against them whether
they came from extreme poverty or abuse
rose up to have successful and happy
lives
right and when
when we read about them or talk to them
or meet them or hear interviews from
them
they talk about mindset they talk about
my mother taught you usually the mother
like my mother taught me that to never
be a victim
my mother taught me that i was capable
of anything and so they had a mindset
they you know where some people have a
victim mindset and then they
that's that's the life they continue to
live
some people have a might a different
mindset and it can lift them out of what
we would consider unprivileged
circumstances right so
you know it makes me question then is
mindset a privilege and
we both know people that have every
privilege afforded to them you know
every one of them
and yet for whatever reason
their mindset is the wrong one and they
can squander all of that opportunity
all of those advantages that they've
been afforded you know
um
and make a mess so i i question whether
mindset is a privilege there are a lot
of privileges in in in life
mindset i think is one of the ones that
is is there for the taking
i
i think about so i was 18 years old
dropped out of university shoplifting
food to feed myself and in that moment i
was entirely convinced that i was going
to be a millionaire what did i do
what did i what did i actively do you
just you're just counting your own point
that mindset is not a privilege no i'm
saying because i think that that i i
have the privilege that that mindset was
given to me by my experiences and maybe
by my biology
i'm wondering why in that situation if
you'd put me and my best friend that i
talked about with the subway example in
the same situation one of us would have
catastrophized and me i just saw it as
this wonderful stepping stone to the
point that i went around my house
videoing my dispatch videoing my dire
situation opening the fridge there's
nothing in it
my first page of my diary on facebook
knows which i kept says i'm keeping this
diary because the tv production company
have asked me to [ __ ]
i liked my own diary because i and i
look back and go this kid was sure yeah
that he was getting out of here well i i
mean i played tricks and games with
myself as well
you know um
i mean i remember i mean some of them
are hilarious but i i did the same thing
you know and and i said i i go back to
the concept of why which is which is
it's the experiences we had when we were
young that formed us into who we are it
wasn't the shoplifting alone it was your
parents it was your friends it was your
teachers like is that a privilege
i mean at what point
everybody has a y and everybody's why is
affirmative
you know
and and so
like i told you about the abuse story
you know
something really positive and someone
really positive came out of that trauma
um
so
you know
i'm struggling to call you use the word
privilege to mindset
because what you're saying is anyone
that anyone who's
had any kind of luck
or turnaround
or
has privilege where anyone who hasn't
and has failed it's because of their
lack of privilege like there's too many
other factors
involved in that in those in those
comparisons
to to to oversimplify it and call it
privilege i'm sure there are privileged
components sometimes involved in that
for sure but
you know when we're if we're
strictly talking about mindset i i i
i think it's uh
it's
i'm not sure i don't think so it doesn't
because
the control of our minds
is the one thing that we own
it's the one thing that
is not
like we we can change the way we view
ourselves and how we treat others um
and i think what's important
and
it's a hard conversation right i think
one thing that's important is
i think we have to have love in our
lives it's from someone
you know like even people who like i
have a friend who came from a very
abusive household
um he he found his grandmother stabbed
to death and the knife was so deep that
she was attached to the bed like that's
how bad it was right
um and yet he had a coach who believed
in him
and so
i think i think
to have someone believe in us
to have one person see a spark in us
helps us recognize that it helps us see
the spark in ourselves
you know uh
it just i think it takes one with only
one person whether it's a friend or a
coach or a parent
a boss sometimes you know who says who
takes a liking to us and almost all of
us
almost all of us
can remember one person in our lives
where it's a coach or a teacher who took
us under their wing and saw something
that we didn't see
uh and every single successful person on
the planet has that person
but i think most of us do most of us
have somebody who
who saw something in us and we are who
we are in part because of that person
having someone in our lives um kind of
links back to something you were talking
about earlier about trying to be less
individualistic in our approach to our
lives and our careers lots of your work
and i was on your video subscription
library and lots of your work has that
as a through line about connection and
people and teams and yeah um
in the in the backdrop of the remote
working world we're living in
um
i guess my first question would be how
do you think that this postcovid world
has been impacted in terms of connection
community teams
and that unity that
should be on the bottom level of our
maslowy and hierarchy of needs well i
mean
obviously it took a step back
you know um
though there are again i always think of
things in terms of balance right and
cost so it's not good or bad it's both
right and so let's weigh both of course
we have freedom of schedule now that we
didn't have we have freedom to live
wherever we want which we didn't have
we have freedom to pick our kids from
school or go to the dentist where we
used to have to ask permission or take
time off we have that freedom now that
we didn't have
um we have
for people who are for people who are um
introverted
they like that they can get their work
done
in the privacy of their own home you
know there are many advantages to remote
working
um
the sharing of ideas is much more
difficult like a brainstorming like
really
really hard to do in a virtual scenario
because it's hyper polite
right you can't interrupt somebody as
easily like when you have a real
brainstorming it's messy it's loud you
step on each other's words you interrupt
each other you have to be like no no and
nobody cares it's the it's the mess it's
the joy of it
right in an online scenario
it gets you literally can't hear people
if everybody's talking at once and
you're constantly apologizing and it's
your turn and you don't have that
wonderful energy i and so i think
brainstorming's suffered
um
and then the obvious one which is
um
which is for a lot of people and i think
if it dramatically affected younger
people more
um
but for for all of us
you you know
when you're done with work
you go out with your friends for a bite
to eat or at the pub and you [ __ ] about
work
and you [ __ ] about your boss
totally healthy and you and you do it in
the with with the friends that whether
it's a good job or a bad job it doesn't
matter you have a you have a place
separated from work
that's your friends that you go and get
it all out right super healthy and you
feel supported and loved and hurt and
all that good stuff that went away
completely
completely and so what ended up
happening and again if you didn't have a
family if you were living alone it's all
these things just get more and more
exaggerated right
so
um what ended up happening was and again
especially young people but for a lot of
other people too
is
we started looking to the people we
spent more time with people now at work
on the on zoom with them all day and
sometimes into the into the evening we
now started spending more time with
these people we didn't have somebody to
go out with afterwards and so we started
looking to work to be that therapeutic
outlet
right and so
what so many people did is first of all
gossip starts to swirl a lot more
because we're now venting and bitching
to each other as opposed to our friends
right so especially if somebody's young
or susceptible like gossips
can take off much quicker
which is very dangerous to a culture
but
what what i've what i've seen is that we
find one empathetic person a the good
listener on the team right and we call
them up and we [ __ ] about our job we
[ __ ] about our boss
but then he keeps going like i don't
know what i didn't what i don't want to
do with my life you know i hate my
boyfriend i hate my girlfriend
i don't know if i should break and all
of a sudden you're dumping all of your
life's problems
on somebody from work who just happens
to be a good listener
and what we're doing is we're increasing
the stress on that person
so
we suffered it in our company i've heard
it from many other companies which is
those people those empaths they're
quitting
and if you ask them why are you quitting
they go because i'm burnt out and you're
looking at their workload and be like i
don't understand like how you burnt out
they're burnt out from taking on all of
everyone else's stress because they're
empathetic everybody else's stress
becomes their stress
right
that's the problem with this which is
and it's good that someone like as
covetez is up like going out with our
friends
and having that
that safe space to vent away from work
is really important so in a cultural
standpoint it's very hard to control for
that like i can't interrupt it i can't
tell them they can't you know they don't
want to go to their boss to talk about
those things but what what
again particularly young people but
others as well but particularly young
people
they're they're recognized that there
are boundaries at work
and you by dumping on one person that
they should take on all your problems
and they listen and they listen and they
listen and they listen and sometimes
they give bad advice but they listen and
listen we're doing a great disservice to
that other person to make ourselves feel
better for a few minutes
i've it's one of the first times in my
life that i've started to think again
about culture design and it's funny
because i ran a business post covered
for seven years we had almost a thousand
people i then left in the middle of
covid and i'm launching businesses after
covert and it seems that not all of the
rules apply and a lot of that's because
of comparison now so that a modern
employee is comparing the
working culture that they're seeing on
tick tock right and linkedin right to
their own and it's almost as an employer
we're competing with a false tick tock
social media narrative that
is um
and people never really know what they
actually want i think as it relates to
culture even me
so when if you ask someone what they
want from their working culture would it
meet their fundamental needs probably
not yeah
um so
my question to you is how are you on a
practical level
what changes have you practically made
or believe are necessary in a
post-covered world
that you wouldn't have maybe stated in a
pre-covered world if any
let me come out to it let me come at it
from a slightly
so if you go back a bunch of years
um
our lives look very different than they
do now
obviously um
we got our sense of
purpose
from church
we got our sense of community
from
you know
whatever bowling league
we hung out with our neighbors they came
over and on the weekends and had
barbecues with us and
work was a place that we
went to make money to pay for our lives
pay our bills and it was also a
different time where we were super loyal
to the company and the company was super
loyal to us
right
and that was
that was life
and then
church attendance started to decline
bowling leagues basically are gone
they've disappeared we don't uh go to
community centers anymore we don't have
our neighbors over on a weekend basis
and so we've our sense so all of those
things we started to look to work to
replace so now we say to work you have
to give me a sense of purpose you have
to give me my social life you have to
give me a sense of community and
belonging
um
and now it's we've added things to that
list now since coverage was like and you
have to agree with all of my politics
and by the way you also have to be my
therapy now you have to be my place for
therapy which is what we were just
talking about right and it is an
impossible standard to put on any
culture that they can do all those
things for you just like
um we've put impossible standards on
romantic partners that they have to be
my intellectual equal they have to be my
they have to be sexually compatible with
me they have to be emotionally
compatible with me they have to share
all of my interests all of my politics
you know we have to vote it for all the
same like these are impossible standards
to put on another human being and we're
literally setting people up to fail
we're setting up business cultures up to
fail as well like literally no culture
can can can live up to that standard and
so
um in pursuit of that
the grass is always greener
you have people who are going from
relationship to relationship to
relationship
worse from job to job to job to job and
when i was younger you know if you
didn't like your job or if you didn't
like your boss the bad news was you had
to stay there for a year because if you
left in anything less than a year you
would hurt your cv they would be like
why did you leave in under a year you
know and now young again particularly
young people
there's no um there's no stigma to
quitting
um and it happens sometimes too quickly
like if your confrontation avoidant and
i've seen it happen confrontation
avoidant i'm too afraid to ask my boss
for a raise so i just quit
i've seen it happen right
or
um i've been here for four months i
don't like the culture i quit
right or i got in trouble at work i hate
my boss i quit like and so people are
quitting so much my fear my fear like i
don't mind if something's super toxic
get the heck out of there most places
are not super toxic imperfect yes
but toxicity is like a like there's a
standard you know and it's a high bar
and
um
uh
or this doesn't fit my values or this
disagree with my politics i quit my fear
is that if you go if we flash forward
five years there's going to be a
disproportionately high number of people
who have eight jobs in five years and
what's going to happen is an employer is
going to look at them be like
i can't take the risk that you're going
to stick around i'm not hiring you
you're you sound like an amazing
candidate but you're too high risk for
me or or and
because you've had so many jobs over
such a short period of time you actually
haven't stuck around long enough to
build up a skill set or know what it's
like to manage a storm
because you've stuck around in the good
times and bailed on the bad times and so
you have now been in the workforce for
five years but you don't have five years
of work experience you have four months
of work experience and so
i don't want you either because you
don't you've never been through a battle
you know and i and i and i see it
happening um
a young person who's been at a company
for eight months
uh goes to their boss and says
i want to raise i want a significant
raise because i'm doing the same job as
those people um those people have been
in the workforce for 10 years i know but
i'm doing the same work as them and i'm
doing good work
that's true you are doing the same work
as them and you are doing good work the
difference is i'm not paying them just
because they've
obliquely been in the workforce for 10
years i'm paying them because
you know how to hoist a mainsail in calm
waters and you can hoist a mainsail in
calm waters as well as they can hoist a
mainsail and calm waters the difference
is they also know to hoist a mainsail in
a storm i don't know if you can always
do main sail in a storm i pay them more
because i know that if if we run into
hard times i know that they know what to
do and i can trust that we can navigate
and i also know that they will teach you
how to hoist a mainsail in a storm
it's like the same reason i buy
insurance i don't expect my house to
burn down but i pay
just in case i'm paying them more for a
skill set that i hope they never have to
use
that's why they get more you know one of
my fears at the moment which is
perfectly linked to what you're saying
is i have a fear and i've never
expressed this openly so this is the
first time so don't all come for me at
once i have a fear that gen z are the
least resilient generation um that i've
ever seen and a lot of it and this
sounds so stupid and not evidence-based
but if you look at what tick-tock is
telling this generation work is and
there was a video that went viral on
twitter the other day out in silicon
valley where it shows like a facebook
employer one of the big tech companies
she arrives at work in the morning she
takes a latte all this free muffins she
goes over and has the free muffin it
shows her in a tick tock literally doing
like 30 seconds of work then she's out
doing some like pottery making class
that work i've put on she comes back to
the desk doesn't have 30 seconds of work
then she's off to a work social
and
i
i reflect on the storms that my father
went through at work
and i i just know so deeply inside of me
that there's no way
some of these younger gen zed people
could weather such a storm without
quitting
um
reporting doing a long linkedin post to
criticize their employee then quitting
employer then quitting and i just i just
fear that
gen z when when i'm hiring people that
are in that generation i almost need to
to go to an extra length just to check
that they can cope with a high-intensity
culture where demands might come on a
saturday
because the world doesn't stop on
saturdays and sundays
so i wanted to get your take on that
um so let's examine both sides right
let's again let's let's think of it
what's the balance and what are the
costs right
um it is a generation
that already was starting to ask these
questions but coveted forced the rest of
us ask these questions too which is what
is the definition of work right like
what does a full-time job mean and these
these are unanswered questions so i
don't have an answer as to what the
future of work is because it's right now
everything's in flux and
we don't things are have not landed yet
right so what is the definition of a
full-time job if i don't come to work
the definition used to be i come in at
eight or nine and i leave at five or six
that was the full-time job now how much
work i did between those hours you know
it was it was face time and we know that
because we've all had jobs where we
stuck around until seven so we got face
times our bus liked us right we've all
done it
right
but facetime is not a thing anymore
and so i have a full-time job and i'm
offered another full-time job and i took
it
and we've seen we see this like
employees who like have productivity
issues and then they say that they're
burnt out and like i know how much work
you have you shouldn't be burnt out how
do they have a second job
and why shouldn't they have a second job
well we pay them benefits so what
like as long as they're getting their
work done do we care when people all
have side hustles even people who've got
full time come to work everybody's got
some sort of little side hustle
so the definition of what full-time
employment is
is up for is up for debate and i think
young people feel
in particular that why shouldn't i it's
my time i can do what i want with it or
i only work 40 hours because those are
my those are my limits respect my
boundaries right
um and
uh
the problem is is i think all of it is
so literal
which is
yes boundaries are important but
the edges of the boundaries are fuzzy
right and it's not like i don't work on
saturdays well i i agree with you i
don't want you working on weekends
this one weekend i really need your help
to finish this project so we can get it
out the door
or you know just i'm i i don't take
meetings after five o'clock i agree with
you i think we should have that life
balance but today i just need you to
work till six to get this one project
done
to recognize that you know so one of the
things they're getting right
is that we're married to work and we
take our phones on holiday you know we
take our computers on holiday with us
and that work has ultimate say on our
time i agree that should be we should
that should go the way of the dodo but
the extreme is not to put these hard
lines everywhere and say i don't do this
as an aside the irony is you know they
demand that we respect their boundaries
and yet they seem to step on every other
boundary about bringing you know
emotional professionalism at work and
dumping all of my problems onto my
colleagues which is
emotionally unprofessional it's like
that's a boundary you can't cross
um
uh but there is good evidence to your
assertion that this young generation
seems less capable to deal with stress
than previous generations that is true
um they are good at
curating you know they've grown up in an
instagram facebook you know tik tok
world where i'm really good at showing
you the life i want you to think that i
lead
and so they're really good at presenting
a confidence
that they don't have
they they sound they sound like they
have all the answers when they don't but
then i see you presenting that live to
me if you're a fellow gen z yeah and i
go
what are my my life's stressful and
difficult and my i had to work really
late and you're having a frappucci lotto
latte whatever yeah at 3am doing pottery
lessons i need to quit yeah it raises
the question what do you want from your
life and what do you want from your work
like why do you have this job
you know
um
if it's just to pay the bills
i mean i i hope we've
i know that is the case for a lot of
people that i have to have a job to pay
the bills and i hope that employers are
good enough that even survival jobs are
a nice place to work you know
uh uh trader joe's great company where
people who have survival jobs is still a
nice place to work you know
but i think the question is is what is
the life that you're trying to build
and if you want a job simply to pay your
bills
and you know there's this concept of
quiet quitting have you heard this one
quiet quitting i've heard this time but
i've maybe i heard you talk about it
well i i i mean it's been written about
right um it's not my concept um but
quiet quitting is this thing where um i
don't quit the job
but i basically will dial back my effort
and give you the minimum so you pay me
to do this job and i will do
the basic minimum amount to do the job
where you can't really fire me because
i'm not really doing anything badly or
wrong
but i'm also not going above and beyond
at all
right so there's this concept of quiet
quitting where people are coming to work
and they're just doing the minimum doing
their hours doing their job
not volunteering or raising their hands
or going and that's it
and
and
it raises the question is that bad
you know and i and i'm a great believer
that
that it's all about expectation
management you know um
like i get asked about amazon a lot like
do i disagree with how amazon has run
and my answer is always the same which
is they never lied
they didn't tell you it's a magical
place to work where it's all kumbaya and
we all like you know we all hang out
with you know unicorns every day it's
really amazing
they're very up they're very open about
it
that it's very very aggressive and very
rough and very competitive
and even the people who love it only
last two years because they burn out
um and so because they don't lie
you know what you're going to get if you
go work there and if you like that kind
of culture then go work there if you
don't like that kind of culture then
don't work there but don't take the job
and then say i didn't know because you
did like apple you know people say well
steve jobs used to drive his people
really hard like but you ask the people
who loved working there
they will tell you yes it was hard and
there was a lot of pressure but i did
the best work of my life and i'm glad i
worked there because i never would have
been able to work to that standard if i
didn't work at apple back in the day
right so the important thing is that
companies are honest about the kinds of
cultures that they have
right it's the lying it's the look how
everything's come by and like and look
no culture's perfect even good ones have
problems and even bad ones have
advantages right but i think it's it's
about managing expectations and i think
it's okay
for somebody to say of themself
look
i'm not a careerist
i am okay with the fact that i will
never be an owner or a senior manager
i want to be paid fairly
i want to do decent work
um but i want work to fit neatly in my
life and not overwhelm it
and i'm going to look for a job where
that is possible and i don't think we're
at the point where we have total honesty
on both sides yet i hope we can get to
the point because there's still stigma
because the older generations like you
and me are looking at if somebody would
say to us i only want to work 40 hours
i'm
i'm willing to push my boundaries
occasionally but really this is just
we would be like well you're not working
here
you know
so i it hasn't normalized yet yeah but i
think it's just a question of being
honest with oneself
and you're allowed to change your mind
as well
like i've decided i do want to be a
little harder driving and i do want i do
have more ambition than i thought you
know
or less but i think i think it's just
about honesty
um
and
this this this point of view is as true
in personal relationships as it is in
our professional relationships
so
i had a conversation with somebody with
somebody recently and i found absolutely
fascinating
and
she
is polyamorous
she has
four boyfriends
right
and
she is very open about it
and
one of the things that that she explains
is
you have to be very honest with
everybody so that everybody knows
what the deal is
you know we're thinking i think what a
lot of people do
is they're dating somebody it's new it's
casual and they're dating somebody else
that's doing casual but they don't tell
them about each other so they both think
that they're more special than they are
or they both are driving towards
something that may or may not be true
because you know you're dating two or
three people and you're to wait and see
which one works out
this in the poly world what i'm learning
is
you tell everybody everything so
everybody knows
and it's very open and honest everybody
knows where they stand you can you can
say i'm not into this i want to be the
soul or i'm okay with this and maybe
something will develop maybe it won't
but the point is it's on the table and i
admire the level of
communication
what i'm hoping
is that we do the same thing
in our professional lives so you sort of
have poly work if you will you know i
have two full-time jobs you know i have
i have three things going or i only want
this kind of relationship and it works
if both parties are really open and
honest
because it's all about managing
expectations
hold on i thought that you were going to
give me all of your attention and all of
your effort and all of your ambition and
you're telling me you only want to work
you want to treat my job as a casual job
like just replace relationship with job
all the same rules seem to apply but if
i knew that i would be fine with that it
would have given you a different job and
had different expectations it wouldn't
have pushed you really hard i would have
given that work to someone else
because i i'm assuming you want to live
your career like i live my career
like i assume that i'm getting into this
relationship and you're getting into it
for the same reasons as me because we
never had a conversation
we are nowhere near that
in terms of social acceptance for that
kind of conversation but i aspire for
that that somebody sits down and says a
part of your cv and part of your
interview says
you know what kind of work-life balance
do you aspire for and how do you view
work
even if you change your mind and then as
if expectations are managed then what's
the problem you've answered one of the
the actual number one questions i wanted
to ask you about today because when i
read your book um the infinite game
one of the big things that changed in my
life was i remember i was on a plane i
read the book started writing some stuff
came back to our office in the uk and i
did a big presentation to all my teams
about how we create a sustainable
company because if what you know if what
you're talking about in the book is is
true then
um and and we're not playing a finite
game here how do we redesign the
business from the ground up so that it
is fundamentally sustainable yep i came
up with this thing called www.work
welfare and world which is the three
reasons why we exist we made um 2020
goals so this was in 2019. 20 goals
before uh 2020 for each of these areas
and i'm thinking about it again a lot
now which is like if i was to design my
business in a way where my team members
would stay working here forever how
would i go about that you've just
answered it by saying the point about
honesty yeah expectations so sitting
them down and saying what you want from
your life because i've never asked that
yeah i'm as you quite rightly identified
i'm presuming they want what i want
exactly um so honestly i've wrote it
here as a question to ask you how do i
get my employees to stay forever okay so
why not like a dictator that sounds
awful but i understand yeah but why
should a
it's
you want to create a place in which
if people want to stay it'll be an
enjoyable place that they can make a
career and and grow within the
organization right
like and for some people who don't have
aspirations for leadership that they can
come and do good work every day and sort
of get fair
raises on you know on a on a regular
basis so that they would you know with
cost of living adjustments etc that they
want to stay there even if it's a middle
level like not everybody aspires to like
be a hard driving you know owner you
know and i think it's about making it a
conversation we we never treated work
like a conversation
you know we treated it like a like a
speech this is how it's going to be
and i think so one of the good things
that's coming out of you know covet and
young people is they're they're asking
questions about why does work have to be
that way and
employers are rebelling against it
because it doesn't fit the way we grew
up and doesn't fit our understanding of
relationships you know and it's just a
conversation that's all it is
and by being honest up front
then
you can say i don't think this is going
to be a good fit for us i don't think
you'll enjoy working here and so if i
employ you
knowing what i know now we will both get
frustrated and
i will either ask you to leave or you
will just tell me you're going to leave
that's how this will end
you know
um
because of misaligned expectations and
so i think
being honest about what you want and who
you are and what your ambitions are even
if they change in the middle you can
knock on the door and say i've changed
my mind
i think i want to stay here forever i
told you i didn't but i really love it
here
you know and i know this from the
military you know some people join the
military because it's a steady job in a
bad economy or because the military will
pay for you to get a college education
and they didn't have the money to get it
without it
so they join the military and then when
there they fall in love with it they
never came in for service they
discovered the service and the
brotherhood and the sisters and decided
to stay you know and some people might
have come in for the service and
realized this isn't for me
so
work should be the same
but uh
i i think i think there needs to be
honest conversation about and like i
said i i've had debates even with my my
partners my work partners you know um
you know
when they say well if we're paying them
a full salary and giving them benefits
they shouldn't have another job and my
question is why not as long as our work
product doesn't suffer as a result like
if they're phoning it in missing all the
meetings then yes absolutely
right like we're paying for certain
expectation of performance but not
necessarily of when they get it done
and so
why shouldn't they have two jobs
uh
but i think again there has to be
honesty
which is we have an expectation that
that
of x and and if somebody says i don't
want to meet that expectation because i
want to have two jobs and
you can adjust for salary that way you
can be like all right then how about we
pay you less and you can have all the
freedom you want
and again it's a conversation
we don't make these things conversations
we make them one way come and by the way
that's from the employee to the employer
too i demand x you know somebody asked
me recently how do i you know i want to
ask my boss for a raise how do i do it
and i said the problem the way most
people ask for a raise is like
i want a 20 raise
i did my research and my job the average
salary on my job you know is x my friend
gets paid x my my friend gets paid x i
know somebody who i work with you know
i'm doing the same work as them so i
want to be compensated equally and i
want a 20 raise
right and so they're positioning
the question
that leaves the employer no choice but
to say yes or no
right it's and even if it's
i can help you get that but this is how
it's going to be like you're going to
have to have certain targets it still
comes across as a no
right because the the request was binary
right and so the advice that i gave to
this person was
stop thinking of your job as an event
and think of your job as a career think
of your job as a continuum
and go to your boss in the middle of
this continuum
um i've worked here for two and a half
years
i've been here through
high times and low times you know i'm
loyal
and my aspiration is to stay here and
grow with the organization
um
uh can you help me figure out a path
that gets me to this salary
it's not a yes or no now now it's like
absolutely i can i can give it to you
today yeah no path necessary
or
absolutely i can we're going to set some
target goals that i want you to hit and
if you can hit them then you'll
absolutely work to that salary but again
it's it's giving it's allowing for
conversation and it's allowing somebody
to to recognize that you view your own
career with the organization as a
continuum that i've been here and i want
to continue to be here so can you invest
in me
take bet can you take a bet on me
rather than meet my demands
and so i think a lot of these things
fail
um because they're poorly presented amen
and this goes once again to you know
this younger generation
who seem to lack the skills for coping
with stress
um not very good at asking for help
um very confrontation avoidant like i
said
so afraid sometimes to have the question
the ask the boss can i have a raise that
they would rather just quit
and it's often with an email that says
you don't appreciate me you don't pay me
enough i was like what you just had to
ask me i would have given you a raise
you know
um
uh
and i think part of it is also that
you know when somebody is anxious about
something
they do poorly present they do make
things binary because there's fear
or anxiety or stress or fear of
rejection what if my boss says no
right can i handle that like all of
these things that come into these very
sort of binary aggressive things and i
always equate all of these challenges at
work to personal relationships like you
can't go to your the person you love in
your relationship
and say i demand this
it's just not going to go well
right but you present a situation you
say i i want us to move through this and
how do we work through this together
and i think that's how these difficult
work conversations need to happen they a
work
a work relationship is a relationship
like any other relationship
you know there's there's trust there's
anger there's uh care there's um
good days and bad days and all of the
same nonsense
a messiness in our personal
relationships are at work as well
you know there's slightly different
standards of professionalism and
emotional professionals and things like
that but
but in terms of it's a relationship like
any other relationships you have to
treat it like a relationship and in fact
go read relationship books if you want
to fix things at work
quick one we have a brand new sponsor on
this podcast which i'm very excited to
tell you about they're a brand called
blue jeans by verizon and they are a
video conferencing and collaboration
tool that has changed the game for our
team so i'm so glad to be working with
them because as you know one of the most
important things for me is when we have
a sponsor it is part of my world it is
part of my life it is part of my
companies as someone who's on calls
pretty much 80 of the day building my
businesses and speaking to my teams all
over the world it's the guaranteed
security that differentiates blue jeans
from all of the other options that are
out there in terms of video conferencing
their enterprise grade security means
you can protect your organization from
malicious attacks and establish real
trust with everyone that joins your
meeting and that is something there are
so many things that make sense and make
blue jeans um a better option than the
sort of competitors out there and i'll
be talking about all of those aspects
those features and the reasons why i use
blue jeans in the coming episodes if you
want to check it out you can head to
www.bluejeans.com
to learn more
when i read about our history as sapiens
or homo sapiens or whatever it appears
that we weren't with one one partner
we're with multiple partners we've now
lived in the society where we're
in arizona told to be with one partner
um is that natural is it human does it
work the stats seem to suggest it's not
really working so well
i mean if i bought a tv and 50 and they
said oh by the way there's a 50 of these
are going to break yeah i wouldn't buy
the tv right i'd maybe you know rent one
right
[Music]
that's funny
uh
esther perel who's
wonderful if you don't know her work
uh
you know she talks about the changing
definition of monogamy monogamous used
to mean i'm in one relationship for my
whole life
now monogamy means i'm in one
relationship at a time
right so
even that definition has changed where
monogamy and people who consider
themselves strictly monogamous
have 15 monogamous relationships
right
over the course of ten how many clothes
i've had six close you know
relationships
they were all monogamous right so these
these definitions are evolving anyway
right
that's number one
number two i
like
that we are having conversations about
the health of relationships like we're
having conversation about the health of
work
and
these things have always existed the
difference is now the stigma of talking
about them
seems to have dissipated
at least in the united states where i
live like it's amazing how many people
are talking about open marriages open
relationships polyamorous relationships
consensual nog monogamy like i don't
even know what all the differences of
all these words are if i'm honest like
they it's there's so many words that
seem to mean similar things
i don't understand the nuances but the
point is is like it's amazing to me how
many people are raising the question
of what is a healthy relationship and i
think one of the things
that boils down for me is it goes right
back to what we're talking about which
is
it base it's based on both parties and
they both get a say and so if you say i
want to live this kind of lifestyle and
you're upfront about it and somebody
says
i'm cool with that then great but if you
lie and say i want to have this kind of
i want to be a strictly monogamous
but you don't really
because you like the person a lot and
you think that if you tell them that you
want a different kind of relationship
you're going to lose them like we're
it's the relation the conversations we
have are largely born out of fear
you know if i tell her what i really
want she won't like me and then i won't
get another date
that's true that is that is a
possibility but if i tell her exactly
who i am and what i want and she likes
me for who i am
then isn't that better
and i think it's the same thing that
we're just talking about work
so i don't think it's right for us to
say
we should be strictly anything
because some people want
one kind of relationship
let me let's rephrase that both people
in that relationship want that kind of
relationship and both people in the
other kind of relationship both want
that kind of relationship
then we just have to respect that we
have different points of view about what
brings happiness as long as you're happy
and it's kind and it's consensual
i i think
we're done
and usually the problems arise when
somebody
has most of these decisions most of
these problems are born out of fear fear
of loss right insecurity in a
relationship jealousy for example this
is the other thing um that friend i was
telling you about who who's super open
and honest about her her life i was
talking to her the other day and she
says
i'm jealous
she says i'm having jealousy
and i'm i'm trying to figure out where
it's coming from
and what i found so fascinating about it
is she
treated jealousy as a feeling
like happy sad angry
where in most monogamous traditional
relationships
jealousy is usually an accusation
right
i saw you look at
the barista that way
right and jealousy is born usually out
of fear
and hyperprotective you know possessive
is born out of fear fear of loss
right and what i found so fascinating
was
she didn't blame her partner for her
feeling of jealousy
she wanted to understand where her
feeling of jealousy was coming from
it was a feeling
right
um and not an accusation
and so i think the same is i
we're to all of this whether we're
talking about work or personal
relationships
everything we're talking about today
comes right back to those human skills
that we are lacking
and i hate the term soft skills
hard skills and soft skills we talk
about right hard and soft are opposites
right
they're hard skills and human skills
these are the hard skills you need to
learn to do your job and these are the
human skills you need to learn to be a
better human being we're really good at
teaching hard skills we're junk at
teaching human skills and human skills
include things like how to listen
how to have a difficult conversation
how to give and receive feedback
how to have an effective confrontation
these are skills that most people lack
we saw it after the murder of george
floyd the number of leaders who after
george floyd was killed
did nothing
they said nothing to their teams not
because they're bad people it's because
they weren't taught how to have a
difficult conversation and so they were
so afraid there's that fear again of
saying something wrong that they would
accidentally offend someone or inflame
the situation that they chose nothing
and i think the same goes in our
relationships we make too many decisions
out of fear
right now as entrepreneurs we understand
risk
right we understand risk
right and that
big reward comes with big risk
small reward comes with small risk no
risk you're leaving it up to somebody
else
and to get over the fact that if i tell
somebody who i really am
that they may not like me
well don't you want to find that out
sooner rather than later because they're
gonna find out
they're gonna the truth is always
revealed sometimes quickly sometimes
slowly the truth is always revealed
eventually
but think about the magic of being able
to say the kind of job you want to have
and the kind of life you want to live
and the kind of relationship you want to
have at the risk that they may not hire
you or they may not go on a second or
third date with you
but think about the opportunity if you
do take that risk i'm thinking about all
the people listening to this right now
who are in a relationship they've been
there for 15 years it's become loveless
maybe they're not having sex anymore
yeah and they're driving on the motorway
now listening to us speak and they're
thinking i really want to have sex with
someone else and if i go home and tell
jane or john whoever it is i don't want
to be gender specific then i just want
to have sex with someone else and i also
want to keep them around they're going
to leave so i can't be honest simon
right so um
once again it goes like asking for a
raise right if you make it binary
you're giving you're backing someone
into a corner
i i realize our marriage is loveless so
i want to start seeing other people
and you can too
you know
and what you're doing is you're making a
binary you're forcing someone into a
binary yes or no which is unfair to
somebody and you're setting yourself up
for probably failure right
as opposed to saying
i love you
you're my life partner you're my best
friend
i never ever want to lose you at the
same time
our relationship is loveless
and i'm struggling
because i crave love and i crave that
kind of affection
and we don't have it and so i'm
struggling and don't know what to do
and i want to know how you feel and i
want to we can work on this together
so you're making it's just like the
raise it's like let's let's make this
now if if you hate the marriage and get
out of the marriage you know like
if you've tried the counseling and it's
broken then that's a different
conversation but if there is the desire
to stay in the loving relationship in
some way shape or form
but you're looking for to fill a place
that's missing then that's a
conversation but it's not a demand or a
request
it's a difficult honey i need to have an
uncomfortable difficult conversation
and we may not get it resolved today
but i want us to promise to stick
through each other stick this stick
through this with each other
so we can figure it out together it
might take us a day might take us a week
it might take us six months but i
i i'm going to be here throughout and
want to go through this with you because
i am struggling in this relationship
somebody else has the right to know that
their partner is struggling in the
relationship and odds are if only one
person is struggling
there's no there's no scenario we're
only one person struggling it's like
when we have a problem with an employee
like if we really can't
they hate their job too like it's not a
shocker
you know and like to start the
conversation like listen i'm struggling
with you i know you hate it here because
it can't be one way
right that doesn't exist
um
i'm pretty sure most of the issues i've
had in my life stem from the fact that i
didn't have an honest conversation
sooner me too
of course me too and i made the mistake
in my life
that
i didn't and i was it was well
intentioned i didn't want to hurt their
feelings
i didn't want to uh offend them or upset
them and so i dealt with the difficult
thing in my head and tried to come up
with the solution that i thought
best looked after my needs and your
needs because i wanted but if i told you
this i would burden you with the stress
of having to figure this out so i'll
figure it out and then i'll make the
decision that i think is best for it
failed every time
because the mistake that i made
is i treated the relationship
as an individual when it's not it's two
people and the problem with a
relationship with two people is i'm not
in total control of the relationship
remember i'm a member of a group i'm a
member of a tribe i'm a member of a team
i'm not in total control of everything
and i have to relinquish some control
and the thing we have to deal with more
than anything is fear it's fear that is
the underlying thing why we don't have
honest conversations
it's why we are hyper aggressive or make
things binary it's because we fear
rejection we fear loss we fear whatever
it is
and it's it's and we can ask for
somebody to reassure us
and we can deal with the fear first
and by saying i'm going to stay here and
an employer or or a
a lover can say
i promise you i will stick this stick
through this with you as well i will not
abandon you we'll get through this
together
that takes the fear down a notch
right that that that we will do this
together
and in in my own relationships
you know coveted
all the bad that came with covet again
you know how i see the world i see the
world is balanced there's bad there's
good and bad in everything right
all of the
struggle and bad that happened in covet
there was tremendous good also
um
and in my own
in my own life
um i had the opportunity like many of us
to
stop
get off the hamster wheel
and then look backwards and saying do
you want to get back on the hamster
wheel
you know or look at all my relationships
like why
weren't they working like where's my
accountability in this
you know
uh what was i doing wrong
and i realized that one of the things i
had to do was i had to not i had to be a
better listener
and so
you know my girlfriend
you know and
when we first started dating she's a
terrible listener
terrible right i mean we joke about it
uh
where i would say babe i need to have an
uncomfortable conversation with you this
is something i'm struggling with
something you said or did that it's
making me uncomfortable i need to work
it through with you and she would start
telling me a problem she had with me
right and so
what i would do is just hold space for
that the conversation would just change
entirely you know
[Music]
but i had to learn what i learned about
listening is this holding space
to learn to hold space for someone
you know to learn
to
to as if as if holding a baby
you know
like
to let someone feel safe telling you
what they need to say
without you trying to fix something or
disagree with something or correct
something
right go on tell me more what else
was the most valuable thing i learned
in covid
and
the nice thing is is when you give that
to someone
weirdly
they
by some weird osmosis
they
gain the capability to give it back to
you
because you've done it if you do it
enough times you can say
this is what came later which is i i
hear what you're saying and i want to
talk about that
but for now
i want to finish the thing that i
started talking about can you can we
just start with that
and you can say it politely
and they recognize that you've held
space for them so many times
that they'll offer you that service and
they know how to do it because they've
seen it modeled the really interesting
thing about that i was thinking about my
own relationships with my with my
partner is the reason why that's so true
for me is because most of the time when
someone is talking and talking and
repeating themselves because they don't
feel like they've been heard correct so
in my relationship with my partner the
fact that we do exactly what you've
described where we literally go give me
a safe space and then i talk means she
only feels like she has to say it once
because she feels like it was heard the
first time right in my previous
relationship
my i remember being i'm gonna be honest
i was in the wardrobe one day and i've
locked myself in there my girlfriend is
banging on the door repeating herself
and i've i'm not proud of this but it's
the truth i
long context i said i'm going for new
year's eve
mean a client are going out to singapore
it's their birthday it's the biggest
client in the world they've asked me to
come it's their birthday she goes i want
to spend new years with eve with you and
i go yeah but i i've told them that i'm
going to singapore she goes i want to
spend new year's eve with you yeah and
that just went oh no and at one point
she's like screaming at me so i just
like go and hide in the wardrobe yeah
she spends all night hanging on the
bloody door like
repeating the same thing over and over
in my new relationship
we
we communicate with more context and we
actually listen when the other person's
speaking so it only needs to be said
once yeah and then she can speak and
then i listen and i repeat it back to
her and then i speak
so what are the things that same right
so this was 10 years ago by the way i'm
not trapping myself in more so so uh you
know uh
the thing that i learned about being in
a relationship i used to come home and
do the same thing like
uh
hey babe you know i got a thing on
friday with a client
right or
i'll give you an even simpler one um
um
the joneses
uh invited us over for dinner on friday
i know that you're free on friday so i i
so i said yes so we'll go for another
joneses on friday and hell ensues you
know
and i was like but i know you're i know
we have no plans you know and so now
what i've learned is when the joneses
call me and say you want to come for
dinner if i go oh my god i'd love to let
me check
and i come home and say hey
the joneses invited us out for dinner on
friday but i want to check with you
first oh my god i'd loved it great i'll
call them and confirm and i've made that
again instead of me well-intentioned
making all the decisions even though i
know
i know exactly what it'll be yes i know
the answer is going to be yes
what i'm doing is including the other
person in the relationship
that's all it is it's making someone
feel seen and heard and included and it
and like i said there's so many great
lessons we can learn from our personal
relationships which we can apply at work
because again
an easy way to understand how i view how
i approach all these things i view it
all as just human beings interacting
with human beings that's all it is and
all the anxieties and fears and egos and
all it applies everywhere
what's the most difficult conversation
you've had to have
with someone
um when we're talking about that honesty
and
communicating as authentically and
openly as we can as soon as possible
what are those difficult conversations
you've had to have or a conversation you
had maybe too late down the line and you
thought i wish i'd had this conversation
sooner i mean
they're not different from anybody else
i mean as
you know
talking about george floyd to my team
talking to george floyd with my black
friends that
was really hard um and i made mistakes
you know like i remember with one of my
friends one of my black friends i was
crying
you know as we were talking about it and
i said to him why aren't you crying
and he said because it's new for you
it's not new for me
he says i'm exhausted
i'm like i'm glad you're having your
experience but it's not my experience
that you're you're this is you're seeing
this for the first time i've seen this
my whole life
you know
like that was that was hard you know to
have that being told at me
to me it's true too
um but
my conversations are the same as i mean
the difficult conversations you know
it's about it's about honesty and
relationship but honestly with with him
you know with somebody on a team
you know if something's not working out
or if you give somebody really hard
feedback somebody who you are really
close with it doesn't mean you're
letting them go but like there's really
hard feedback you need to give to
someone
and learning to deliver it with love
learning to be a matter of fact
you know one of the mistakes i would
always make you know this you know these
all these theories about give somebody
the you know the compliment sandwich
tell them something good tell them thing
you want to tell them tell something
good doesn't work because it's it's
[ __ ] generic something good really
specific something bad and [ __ ]
generic something good you know seven
good things one bad thing [ __ ]
[ __ ] generic generic generic really
specific
so it doesn't work in my opinion
it doesn't work like you if it's really
it's like you know i really like that
you show up to work with a smile
and there's one other thing i need to
talk about you know
um
but what i've learned is when delivering
good news
be very emotional
and when delivering bad news um remove
the emotion
and so like bad news at work especially
you know when we sit with time someone's
like
um
ah so
i don't i don't want to belabor this um
you've been with us for a long time uh i
need to
this is really hard i need to give you
some
difficult feedback
i'm infusing all of the emotion into
this
right but to be dispassionate about it's
like hey i need to give you some
difficult news i need to just have a
really blunt conversation with you about
something that's going on at work and
it's going to be really hard for you to
hear but i need to tell you boom here it
is
it
it people appreciate it when we're just
straight with them
and you know not infuse all the extra
emotion
um but you know
yeah i think the same i think the same
is
again same as true in all relationships
i've always found that i i struggle to
use the word employees
and
you just went to use the word then and
you changed it to team yeah is that
something that you also the reason why
the reason why so i use whenever i'm on
the podcast i talk about it but my my
team will never hear me and if they
might not have noticed this but this has
been the same for 10 for about 10 years
i will never in a in a chat set call
them and call people that work in my
company employees yeah it seems to be
somewhat of a violation of my values
somehow and i just noticed you went to
say the word
team someone on my team that's what you
did yeah i mean i i do the same i mean i
i
when i show up to a group called my k
team and like yeah then
you know um
employee to me is a technical word
you know yeah i don't mind talking about
employees when we're talking about
generic company stuff
um i don't mind referring to employees
when i'm talking to an insurance when
i'm talking about insurance
you know or benefits you know it's like
it's a technical term that i think is
totally fine to use in technical times
but when i'm referring to people and
those people have names and faces
then they're the team
do you you know this andrew tate thing
this and you take guy has been in a lot
of the headlines you know he is probably
a good thing you don't um he's been in
it's this guy that kind of came out with
this kind of pro
you know pseudo weird kind of strange
masculine approach his base thesis i
guess is saying that men
young men and men generally are missing
something in their lives that the modern
world hasn't given them um jordan
peterson has alluded to similar things
jordan peterson's been on this podcast a
few times it's got me thinking about
gender differences in our needs in in
the world a lot of people there's a lot
of people in like youtube in the
self-help space that are saying men have
these unmet needs because the world is
becoming more equal
and they are lacking their sense of
purpose and men are meant to be i don't
know tribe leaders and all these kinds
of things
and when you look at the the
suicide rates in our country the single
biggest killer of men under the age of
40 is
themselves it's suicide and so i've been
i've been mulling this
is is the is is there gender differences
in your view these are all very
difficult topics i understand but
and is are men in particular having
certain needs go unmet because of a
changing world in your view
everybody has unmet needs because of a
changing world
fact
are there gender differences of course
there are gender differences and how we
respond to men versus how we respond to
women is different
a friend of mine who
was um
she was she
three things happened to her
simultaneously in the military three
things happened to her simultaneously
any one of them would would be difficult
but all three of them happened her at
the same time she was promoted to senior
management she became lieutenant colonel
she was deployed for 13 months
12 months
and she was given her very first command
okay so any one of those things is a is
a trial and all three happened at once
right
and
she took over a job where the previous
five leaders had all been fired it was a
poorly run
uh group
she would be working with people from
different forces so she's in the air
force she'd have air force and army
reporting to her some of whom were much
older than her and much more experienced
than her
and
she is a hard driving you know
passionate young officer who said i'm
going to turn this group around and i'm
going to prove to everybody that i can
turn it around
i've been practicing leadership i've
been studying leadership i want to be a
great leader
and it was a failure
like it was people weren't they were
ignoring her
they weren't taking her seriously and no
matter how she powered up it didn't work
and
um
every night
she started she would cry herself to
sleep
and started regretting being in the
military all she wanted to do was go
home she didn't want to be stuck on
deployment anymore what was something
really exciting now became a regret
and
she didn't know what to do she was
failing
which was hard for her to deal with
alone i mean as it was and so she
decided to give up
and she
said i'm
i will not turn this group around
so if i'm gonna fail at my job then i
might as and i'm stuck here for another
six months and so is everybody else i'm
going to change my mandate and instead
of turning this group around i'm just
going to ensure that the rest of their
time here they really enjoy it
i'm just going to make it more fun for
them to come to work every day because
they're also away from their families
and stuck
and then something strange really
started to happen they started to listen
to her take her seriously they started
to respect her more and she ended up she
ended up being very very high performing
at the end and the group completely
turned around
because
on her way in she made it about herself
and she made it about the metrics and
she made it about the performance
the lesson she learned was if you make
it about the people
then the people will take care of
everything else
and i remember i sat down with her a
week or two after she got back and she's
telling me this whole story for the
first time you know after she got back
and she started crying
and and when she said to me jesus i have
never felt a joy
so deep
as seeing someone discover that they are
capable of more than they thought they
were
which is very different than i'm going
to turn this around
so in in her telling me
this she said one of the big lessons she
learned is there is such thing as female
leadership
and she had a conversation with one of
the army one of the soldiers
and like why didn't you listen to me
like why why was it so difficult why did
we struggle
and he said point blank because when a
male officer yells at me
right
i take it
i hear it i move on right it's fine
when you yelled at me i felt like my
mother was yelling at me
and it was more difficult
you know so there are gender differences
in how we respond
to each other because it is a mom dad
thing right we respond differently
um
and
um
and
men are sometimes
not always but men are sometimes better
at just being told blank by another guy
just do this and you go i'll just do it
but when you create gender it creates
all kinds of other other interpretations
and associations like our mothers
so i think we cannot discount those
and you know traditional male leadership
qualities are things like decisiveness
aggression you know those kinds of
things traditional female
um
qualities are things like patience you
know maternal instinct
uh empathy
and i think the mistake we've made
across all leadership is we teach male
leadership we teach decisiveness and we
teach aggression and these are the
things we teach we teach that to
everybody and the reality is is what
makes great leaders is they have a
balance
and what we should be teaching is more
of female leadership
and you know all leaders should take on
the qualities of patience and empathy
you know this this is the irony
um
and so uh
i think we i i think we do need to teach
those skills i mean those this goes back
to what we're saying before these are
those human skills you know women get my
work a lot quicker than men when i was
starting my career you know women were
just not and be like yeah
yeah what do you
of course and men would be like what are
what are your case studies
and what cases studies you have to prove
your your model
you know
men would fight with me on some of the
details and women just inherently
intuitively understood that the humanity
of the work that i was preaching just
made sense
and there's space for that and so yeah i
think i think female leadership and
those qualities are just necessary
everywhere but yes there are differences
and they cannot be discounted it's
difficult to talk about them though
isn't it it feels like a minefield even
when i talk about gender differences it
feels like i'm going to step on a mind
somewhere because
you're entirely correct and my previous
company was a managing director was a
woman and
i think the business was more successful
because of those qualities you've
suggested empathy care patience
um
she was much more
honest about uh
honest about forecasts yeah and how how
the business was going to perform versus
a male leader i mean this is such a
narrow example so it's not necessarily
truth but a male managing director we
had who was extremely
exaggerating and very very very
ambitious about forecast that we never
realized that makes sense that that's
consistent and and i think you know
there's lots of data on this you know
men you know when they apply for a job
and they say we need these ten things
and if they have six out of the ten they
apply for the job and women won't apply
for the job unless they have nine or ten
of the qualities
you know
men are a little you know i've seen it
happen in meetings where you know
there's a male entrepreneur and like the
client is saying you know we'd love this
to have we'd love to have this and they
kind of have it and the guy goes we can
totally do that
yeah you know and they'll sell it
they'll sell it right there and then
figure it out later yeah and i've sat in
meetings with a female entrepreneur who
has almost that like they're really
close and i and that you know somebody's
saying we would love this i'm like do
you have that they're like it's not
we haven't tested it yet
i'm like you have it tell them you have
it they're like what's no it's not
perfect yet
you know
um
so yeah i mean i i mean some of it some
of it is a cultural as well
i have a female entrepreneur friend who
has a theory and i have to stress this
is her theory
exactly exactly right she believes men
make better entrepreneurs than women
she believes men make better
entrepreneurs than women okay yes
and the logic is
uh that
uh
as when we're young
traditional roles for the most part
still exist that if you want to go
to the prom
[Music]
generally
the boy asks the girl right it's it's i
think it's softening but it's
traditional roles are still
still there which means from a young age
boys
learn
to muster up courage take a risk and get
rejected
and then they have to do it again
and then they have to do it again
right and so you flash forward to
adulthood
and
men
who learn that skill of asking of taking
a risk
facing rejection being rejected and then
trying again
makes them resilient entrepreneurs
where for for again assuming traditional
roles are played you know if if
a
a woman who hasn't learned the skill of
risk rejection
um is more afraid of the risk
as an adult
now we could argue that with online
dating you know swiping left and right
that everybody's losing the skill
you know
we could argue
that nobody has to take a risk because
you just swipe right you don't know that
they swipe left on you they think maybe
they just didn't see you so you only get
the oe it connected but you nobody ever
gets rejected
so are we building that goes back to the
original conversation of a young
generation that's less capable of
dealing with stress than older
generations like
much there are fewer opportunities to
risk reject have to try again
right and the things that we learn as
kids these social interactions they they
they do become skills as adults
and so you know is it a softening of a
generation
should not we be asking both
you know you know
uh uh
boys and girls
you know shouldn't we not be asking them
to to go to the to learn to both have to
learn to take risk as opposed to taking
the risk away from everybody i don't
know no you know what the what i will
say is i've had two
very successful um women entrepreneurs
on this podcast who've said the same
sentence which is as women in the in the
workplace we typically don't ask for
raises as much as our current parts
and
that kind of supports what you're saying
there which is men have at some point
learned to just ask
for the things that they they they want
whether it's a raise whether it's a job
whatever it is you know but i think i
think you know the theory here that that
my friend posed
is that it
doesn't come from
our experiences of dating when we're
younger that we build these skill sets
that benefit us
later in life as entrepreneurs the whole
it's not risk reward it's risk reject
risk rejection
whenever i speak to someone that does a
lot of interviews and conversations and
talks you know
um online a lot i always i always try
and think of questions that i would ask
them that they've never been asked
before
and one day i remember it was actually
after you left when we were in the
studio in l.a i thought to myself if i
was going to interview myself
it would probably be the most
interesting interview in the world
because i know all of the [ __ ]
and i know all of the stuff that no
one's ever asked me that i've maybe
scattered away from or whatever
if you were sat in my chair and you were
interviewing simon today
what does what are some of the questions
you would have asked you to get to
to get the most interesting stuff out of
you
maybe just give me one question i think
you've done a pretty good job i mean
i think the best interviews are
conversations
i think the best interviews have no
agenda but the interviewer
has genuine curiosity
i think the best interviews are
open-ended questions
that are difficult
and in this case of your interviews you
know you are pretty blunt with an with a
question
that doesn't leave a lot of wiggle room
you know a lot of questions i can wiggle
out of and yours less so
um but they give an opportunity to me to
think out loud you know
i think a lot of the questions you asked
today i i haven't thought about or if i
have i haven't sort of codified it and
what
you heard were not answers but you heard
me thinking
you know and if you go back and listen
to them i probably they're probably sort
of like sort of bounce around a little
bit because you hear me trying to get to
an answer they're not answers i'm trying
to get to an answer and those for me are
the best
um because i walk away feeling
enlightened because i got to think
um where usually the answers the
questions are
i've heard them all before they're very
focused on my work
when you wrote this when you wrote that
you know what were you thinking
and i don't learn anything
so when you ask me about my work i know
the answers when you ask me not about my
work you asked me about life and you
asked me about challenges that the world
is facing
that's what i love so you know i think
you've done that and so the questions
that i ask myself are the questions you
asked me okay i'm going to ask you the
question i'm not copying out it's no
different genuinely you're very good at
what you do i will ask you the question
i would ask myself okay which is what is
the greatest i was just thinking about
it then what is the greatest fear you
have about how you're currently living
your life
what is the greatest fear i have about
how i'm currently living my life
that i'm not 100 honest with myself
because i'm not honest with myself i
won't be honest to others
um
you know
and when somebody asks me a question
that that i'm afraid of the answer not
because i'm afraid of offending them
but i'm
i'm i'm afraid of how i feel about the
answer myself
you know
uh
i think that would be it have you got a
suspicion that you're not being
completely honest with yourself
uh
i think that all of us have a capacity
to rationalize
it's
it's one of the genius things about
being a human being we can rationalize
anything
you know i can make any decision the
right decision
you know
and i can convince somebody of it as
well you know like this is definitely
the right decision
um and i think it's that it's that gut
that deep down inside to be truly honest
even if the answer is i don't know
um
or i'm scared
or i'm uncertain
or
i want this and i feel like i shouldn't
want it
do you have a suspicion that you're not
being honest with yourself in a certain
area of your life
do you have a suspicion that i'm not
being honest yourself i don't think it's
a suspicion i think it's i think it's
confirmed
i don't think i suspect it i think i
think
i think i'm
i like every human being
have have elements of of self-doubt and
security of course
you know and
and can convince myself of anything you
have self-doubt in certain areas of
course
that's none of your business but that's
a good enough phone so yeah those are
those are those are my those are those
are my that's that's like not i i'm i'm
pretty open but
there are things that i want to resolve
myself i want to resolve with myself
before before
i'm able to share them because if i
share them it has to benefit others
yeah and you have to have done i guess
work on i have to do work because and
i'm happy to share stuff that's in my
life
if i believe that that conversation even
if it's unresolved has a benefit to
others maybe it does maybe it doesn't i
find it really interesting is you know
as i do this podcast where my line is
what won't i share and there is things i
won't share yeah it feels like
maybe i'm bullshitting myself
maybe it's quite a lot of stuff i don't
show or i twist it to make myself look
better people like to be a hero you know
i mean or or like
i think we live in a world that we have
confused
vulnerability with broadcasting our
feelings
right and going on a podcast
or worse
sitting in your bedroom with your phone
on self view
and broadcasting your breakup or your
anger or whatever it is on tick tock or
whatever your medium of choice is
you know
is not vulnerability even if you're
crying
have that exact same conversation with
those exact same words with somebody you
love and see how difficult that is
that's vulnerability
and i i just the idea of broadcasting
everything i've i i think it's you know
putting pictures of
me as a baby and my dad holding me and
happy father's day dad i love you my
dad's not on freaking instagram what am
i why don't i just call my dad and say
happy father's day i love you as opposed
to like i think it's hilarious that our
need to broadcast everything
and we think that's vulnerability and
it's not it's broadcasting our emotions
which are different so i think
you know
um
those conversations that you're
struggling to have
and like the ones that i'm the ones that
i won't share it's not that i won't
share them with anybody it's that i
won't share them with you
because i like you
but we're not you're not my soul mate
you're not the person that i confide in
i will absolutely share those deep those
things that i'm struggling with but i'll
share with somebody who can hold space
for me with love
not with the desire to make a good
podcast
you know
um it's almost an old-fashioned
perspective you know so so
the mistake people will make is to not
share them with anyone
and when i say it's not your business it
doesn't mean it's not out of anyone's
business
i absolutely do share those things
because it would be unhealthy not to
but i want to help i want to share those
things in a really safe
really safe magical space with somebody
who loves me no matter what and kiss me
no matter what and will stand by me no
matter what
interesting no one has ever responded
like that before which i think is um
which is amazing in and of itself
because it's really it's really changed
my perspective on a few things
as you know
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest yes they
have no idea who they're asking it for
correct
i wonder i'd love to know how somebody
answered my question last time
we could look it up i'll tell you yeah
often
um
it's a slightly interesting one because
it feels like it's something we've
discussed in many respects um
what's one conversation
what's one conversation you haven't had
which you know you need to and why
haven't you had it are you willing to
have it
yeah won't share the answer and yes i
will
because you'd rather have it with the
person i'd rather have it with the
person like i i'm like to me to
broadcast it now
before i've talked to the person
seems unfair and disingenuous
and i think
you know it's kind of like
when
like there's a respect you know it's
like when you hear
about
you know there was a tragedy
and people were killed and they don't
release the names before they've told
the families they tell the families
first then they release the names
just out of respect
and i think the same goes for these
kinds of conversations which is i think
we owe it to the people in our lives we
love and care about to let them be the
first to hear the thing that has to be
said rather than the second or the last
i think it's just
it's just
that's how i want to be treated too i'd
want to be the first to hear it if
somebody has something to say to me
it's just respect
so yes there are things and they will be
said
i completely agree and enjoy it really
it really ties in nicely with your
earlier point about having a
conversation as soon as possible an
honest conversation as soon as possible
but also i guess the the adjacent point
to that is having it with them first
yeah making sure they don't find out by
the grapevine or podcast can i can i can
i yes 100
and i've heard stories of like people
hearing about things on television you
know yeah and people losing their jobs
they found out through somebody else
things like that um
uh can i just share one funny story
about being honest before we close
um
honesty always has to be honest right
like honesty is really easy just tell
the truth
but
honesty doesn't have to happen in the
moment
and this is a lesson i've learned right
so i went to see a friend of mine's play
and it was
easily
the worst thing i've ever seen in my
entire life
i mean
[Music]
if she wasn't in it i would have walked
out
it was awful
and at the end of the performance i hung
around with the you know close friends
and family in the in the foyer and she
eventually came out still in costume
still in makeup and she knows i'm an
honest broker
so after the thanks for coming the first
question was what did you think
right
now i'm an honest person but she's all
jacked up on adrenaline she's all jacked
up on emotion now is not the time but
the problem is i can't lie you know we
do it all we lie all the time to protect
other people's feelings you know you get
given a gift it's the ugliest sweater
you've ever seen in your life and they
go what do you think you go oh my god i
love it thank you you don't love it
right so don't say you love it to
protect them right
but you don't have to be honest in the
moment so what i said was oh my god i'm
so proud of you it was so amazing to be
here and watch you do your thing i've
never sat in the audience and seen you
do your thing before it was so much joy
to see you on stage all of that was true
and that was it done
the next day when all the adrenaline had
come down and there was no more emotion
i called her up and said can i tell you
what i thought of the play she goes yeah
and then i told her point by point why
it sucked but we had a we had a rational
conversation the next day and i think we
make this mistake all the time in our
relationships which is we think we have
to be honest in the moment but we don't
read the room and understand that
there's too much emotion involved to
have a rational conversation you know
somebody's mad at us and we're good this
is not the time for rational feedback
you meet emotion with emotion you meet
rational with rational you can't mix the
two
and sometimes we're rational but they're
emotional which means we have to stand
down
right so what i've learned about honesty
is we have to be honest but we can
actually delay
you have to meet rational with rational
and emotional with emotional let me give
you some honesty then um i i
i went um
i went on your video subscription
library absolutely love it i'm a member
now you'll see my name in the back end
um looked at the live the live courses
coming up watch loads of the videos
amazing it feels like it feels like it's
too cheap to be honest because the
amount of value there around all of the
things that are foundational to my life
my businesses my relationships
everything it feels like it's a little
bit too cheap it's like a couple of cups
of coffee yeah for a month and i can
just binge all of your content all of
the videos and you've got all of these
other instructors on that yeah who are
teaching the lesson it feels very cheap
that's not the thing the only thing i
thought i thought oh i don't know if
this is this is the best is the name
go on
i
the word subscription for me is
a bad thing give me another name
uh simon's unit simon sinek university
simon's library any of these things
would have made me way more so i was
thinking about the name and i was
thinking video video subscription
library video yeah it's not really why
i'm here subscription it's not it's not
a great one
yeah
so i was i was just thinking this would
change it but no i'm so i i mean i have
it but i have no emotional connection to
anything and the reason why
it's a technical thing and we call it a
technical thing i watched your last
episode and you talked about honesty in
it and i was thinking this is way better
than it sounds yeah you've got and i
have to say this because people have to
check it out
basically the the you've distilled your
books into actionable courses there's
live classes there's all of your content
on there yeah everything you've ever
done it feels like i'm ripping you off
by being a member that's very nice i
genuinely think if i hang around there
my life would be better if i hang around
for an hour a day my life will be so
basically we'll change the name which
will make people feel even more value
and then thanks to this conversation
we're going to charge people more you
should genuinely i mean we've i haven't
been i you know i've had this
conversation with before with people
which is i know that our wide discovery
course i know there are people who offer
sort of all kinds of purpose-finding
courses that they charge 1500 bucks for
you know and
i know because i've been told that our
course is like a thousand times better
than a lot of things on the market and
yet we charge like i don't know i think
i can't remember the prices it's like it
was 20 something dollars for a month but
i mean but but if you take the y
discovery course it's like 85 bucks 125
i can't remember
but but it's low
and the reason is is because i believe i
have a responsibility to let
everyone who wants to learn their why
learn their why and not those who can
just afford fifteen hundred dollars
and you know the way we attempted to
price that product was what would be
slightly expensive for a college student
a bloody college student you know doing
150k debt right so fraction of what you
so so that's my point which is like 1500
is
um exclusive
and i would rather
s i would rather try and make it up
in volume because i want more people to
learn their why so
you know is that too low i mean it is a
trial right now just you know we just
launched it so it's full of bugs so you
know i'm sure one of the the mental
things was like you know
we probably shouldn't like we should
probably like ease people into it just a
little buggy um i appreciate the
feedback um but it is important for me
to keep prices relatively low because
it's more important to me that people
learn the stuff than don't the price
fine i want it to be cheaper for my own
selfish needs right it was actually the
name i thought did it disservice okay
i'm gonna that was it simon's library or
simon's university i'm done yeah uh i
have no i have no emotional attachment
to it whatsoever so we'll make that
change thank you very much for the
feedback
everything's written in pencil exactly
thank you thank you for coming again
simon honestly it's a huge it's a choice
and i learned so much from these
conversations that i wish i actually
need to go back through this episode
with my own notes so i can um change my
business and my life for the better
thank you so much it's a joy i i learn i
learn as much if not more than you do so
i really appreciate you having me it's
amazing we'll do it again sometime i
hope so thank you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has about 100 calories in total
while also giving you 20 grams of
protein
if you haven't tried the cure protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as
pretty much any milkshake on the market
just mixed with water it's been a game
changer for me because i'm trying to
drop my calorie intake and i'm trying to
be a little bit more healthy with my
diet so this is where heel fits in my
life thank you hill for making a product
that i actually like the salted caramel
is my favorite i've got the banana one
here which is the one my girlfriend
likes but for me salted caramel is
the one
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]